okay so in this presentation we're going
to go over the female reproductive
system and talk about the menstrual
cycle and ovulation so let's go ahead
and get started so when we first examine
the female reproductive system you know
let's start with mentioning the uterus
also known as the womb you know this is
a very thick muscular organ in a woman's
groin pelvic area that protects the
developing embryo for basically nine
months this is where a human embryo will
develop for nine months until being
birthed and on the left and the right of
the uterus are two organs called ovaries
found on each side of the of the uterus
and what I mean by they're inside what I
mean by that is in comparison to male
testes you know women's ovaries are in
her core body but male testes are not
housed in the core of a man's body
they're actually suspended down in a
man's scrotum where it's a degree or two
cooler than the core man's temperature
so that's what I mean by ovaries are
found on the inside they're internally
in the core of her body and they're on
the left and right side of the uterus
and the ovaries main mainly produce a
hormone called estrogen now when a woman
reaches whoa when a girl reaches the age
of puberty these hormones right here
released from the pituitary gland
follicle stimulating hormone labeled FSH
and luteinizing hormone labeled LH these
two hormones when a woman reaches
puberty are began to be released from
the pituitary gland and these hormones
travel to the ovaries through the
bloodstream and in response the ovaries
will produce large amounts of estrogen
and this marks the beginning of the
woman's menstrual cycle and ultimately
over the next few years the the woman
will will develop sexually develop
female sexual care
mystics once a month in aid will go
through a view Latian and ultimately if
that egg is fertilized will grow into an
embryo in the uterus so that's what this
presentation is going to discuss okay
I'd like to refresh our memory with a
process we learned a few months ago
called oogenesis or low Genesis have
heard it pronounced both ways and this
is the production of an egg cell also
called an ovum again this process takes
place in a woman's ovaries if you recall
from earlier when we learned about this
meiosis has two rounds of division
meiosis 1 and meiosis 2 so here is a
cell called an oocyte and watch what
happens during meiosis 1 that site will
divide in the 2 cells but notice how the
division of the cells is not equal the
cell on the left has contains the
majority of the cytoplasm and the cell
on the right is a smaller cell that
eventually we call a polar body and
ultimately is going to dissolve and die
well after meiosis 1 occurs these cells
kind of enter a hybrid native state and
in many cases this will last 12 13 years
until a woman begins until a girl begins
you know her her menstrual cycle around
the age of puberty age 12 age 13 so for
about 12 or 13 years these cells are in
this hibernative state now that meiosis
one has ended and during the menstrual
cycle then meiosis number two will begin
if an egg is fertilized meiosis number
two will begin I should say and if an
egg is fertilized by a sperm cell
meiosis number two will then proceed and
the you notice how the two cells have
become four cells but again when they
divide like this they don't divide the
cytoplasm is not divided equally only
one out of the four cells will end up
reaching maturity in and then the sperm
will the nucleus of the sperm will fuse
with the new
is on the egg to create a zygote the
other three are called the polar bodies
and again will dissolve and disintegrate
and then one thing to remind ourselves
is that egg cells human egg cells have
23 chromosomes because they're haploid
and I want to just just kind of mention
that again meiosis number two doesn't
even occur until a sperm cell from a
male has penetrated the egg cell so
meiosis number two doesn't even occur
most months because a woman doesn't
become pregnant most months of her
menstrual cycle just kind of a fun
little fact
so let's actually talk about what
happens to that egg cell well the
process of the menstrual cycle is really
controlled by a few hormones here the
hormone estrogen progesterone
luteinizing hormone and follicle
stimulating hormone these hormones
really control the process that we're
going to discuss and so one thing I want
to mention is that eggs are housed
inside of a inside of the ovary but
notice in the picture I have a white
circle with an e in it that's an egg and
that white e is contained in a larger
blue circle that's a follicle so notice
how there are follicles inside of the
ovary now there are millions of these
follicles I've just drawn one for
simplicity and ultimately in the first
Oh 10 12 13 days of a woman's menstrual
cycle these follicles are going to start
to mature and help to grow an egg on the
inside and around day 13 day 14 around
day 14 is when this process called
ovulation occurs and in my animation
watch what happens to the blue follicle
the blue follicle is just broken open
releasing an egg that's ovulation this
usually happens around the 14th day of a
woman's menstrual cycle well during the
next L 5 6 7
days that egg is going to travel down
the fallopian tube and ultimately into
the uterus
so it takes five six seven days for this
egg to travel through the the length of
the fallopian tube and that's usually
where fertilization will occur in the
fallopian tube if a woman is sexually
active and the egg encounters a sperm
cell usually fertilization occurs in the
fallopian tube and then ultimately the
growing embryo will implant itself into
the lining of the uterus
now that broken follicle actually
collapses further and it becomes a
structure that we call the corpus luteum
and in my animation I now just have it
labeled CL but notice how the CL the
corpus luteum is still inside of the
ovary and all it does now is it releases
hormones that will eventually prepare
the lining of the uterus for an embryo
to implant if the woman becomes pregnant
so that ruptured broken follicle still
has a role to play again it kind of
collapses in on itself and forms what we
call the corpus luteum and ultimately
these hormones released are going to
help help the the zygote grow and
develop and ultimately to implant in the
lining of the uterus if a woman becomes
pregnant
so let's look at what happens if an egg
is fertilized versus if it's not
fertilized so in the picture here we
have a sperm and an egg about to about
to join and in fuse with one another
well my animation here comes an egg cell
and notice how it was just fertilized by
a sperm cell a zygote has been created
well let's follow that zygote as it
continues to move down the fallopian
tube the zygote will begin to divide
through the process of mitosis as it
travels through the fallopian tube
towards the uterus notice how the cells
have divided one became 2 2 became 4 and
ultimately this growing embryo this
growing lump of cells is multiplying by
the process of mitosis let's follow that
some more so now that the love before
cells has multiplied to become 8 cells
and the process of division continues
down the length of the fallopian tube
and ultimately that lump of cells will
eventually implant into the lining of
the uterus which is the next one next
step in the process that we're going to
see right now in the animation
so here comes that lump of cells which
is by now is what we call a blastocyst
so this large lump of cells called a
blastocyst will implant into the lining
of the uterus and there the blastocyst
will continue to grow larger and larger
and larger into an embryo and ultimately
nine months ladies the nine months later
the baby would be born well let's talk a
moment about the presence of twins you
know you might know that some twins are
identical and what's the difference
between identical twins and what are
called fraternal twins well identical
twins can be traced back to the same egg
and also the same sperm watch this so
here comes one egg and one sperm and one
zygote is created right now there's no
twins right now this is just eventually
going to grow into one human watch what
happens in some cases the zygote will
divide by mitosis to become two cells
and then their lump of cells continues
to multiply and as the lump of cells
continues to multiply again right now
there's only one one embryo growing
inside of this woman but watch what
happens in the next division sometimes
this happens where the lump of cells
will actually split into two lumps which
will then continue down the fallopian
tubes and when they reach the lining of
the uterus will implant both of them
into the uterus
so here come both of those lumps of
cells and they both implanted into the
lining of the uterus now these would be
I continue to grow into identical twins
because we can trace them back to the
very same egg inspire the very same
zygote how is that different from what
are called fraternal or non identical
twins so when we look at fraternal twins
every now and then this happens in a
woman's menstrual cycle instead of one
egg cell being released throughout
through a from ovulation or due to
ovulation maybe two egg cells are
released during a month during the
monthly cycle and if the woman is
sexually active and both egg cells are
fertilized by a sperm cell then you're
going to have not just one zygote but to
notice how the two zygotes might they
might not even be the same gender one
zygote might have an X chromosome from
the egg and an X chromosome from the
sperm and therefore will develop into a
girl but the other zygote might have an
X chromosome from the mom and a Y
chromosome from the sperm and could
develop into a male so fraternal twins
they might be the same gender but they
might not be there they're really just
Brethren's brothers and sisters or
siblings that are just born on the same
day and notice how their DNA is
different because we can trace them back
to a different egg and a different sperm
with a different combination of genes
well eventually these two zygotes will
grow and develop and grow and develop
just like we saw before and ultimately
these lumps of cells will continue to
travel down the fallopian tube
and ultimately the two blastocysts
the two lumps of cells would implant
into the lining of the uterus and each
of them would continue to grow and
develop into its own embryo and then its
own baby
but again just reminder that one might
they both could be male they both could
be female or they could be different
gender because again they're not
identical we can trace them back to a
different sperm in a different egg at
their at their fertilization moment
okay well what happens if an egg is
unfertilized there goes an egg through
the fallopian tube and ultimately if
let's say the woman was not sexually
active during this monthly cycle or
let's say the woman was using birth
control and therefore sperm from a male
never fertilize the females egg what
happens then the notes say the egg is
going to leave the uterus through what's
called menstruation let's examine that
so what happens during menstruation is
now that the egg has reached the uterus
and has not been fertilized by a sperm
cell the the next menstrual cycle the
next round of the menstrual cycle will
begin and this begins by clearing out
the lining of the uterus and the egg
that was never fertilized and so during
menstruation the lining of the uterus
sheds and and menstrual bleeding occurs
which kind of clears out the lining of
the uterus and also the egg that was
never fertilized and ultimately this
will prepare the uterus for the next
menstrual cycle in which maybe the woman
does become pregnant but that's what
menstruation is is the flaring out of
the lining of the uterus and the
clearing out of the egg that was never
fertilized so now let's go through the
menstrual cycle the 28-day lengths
menstrual cycle you know this graph down
here these this picture here I think is
going to be really helpful
it shows changes that are occurring in
three different areas during the
menstrual cycle the bottom of the graph
kind of shows the upward and downward
rise and fall of the four major hormones
in the middle it shows the lining of the
uterus that changes that occur in the
lining of the uterus
notice how the lining of the uterus is
very thin in the first few days and then
it begins to thicken as the month
progresses and the top area of the
diagram kind of shows changes that are
occurring inside of a woman's ovary the
follicle maturing the mountain the
follicle breaking open and the egg being
released during ovulation and then then
the development of the corpus luteum so
this uh I'll be referring to this
picture a few times during the next part
of these notes so the average menstrual
cycle lasts for about 28 days now we can
subdivide those 28 days into really
three separate phases
and one is called the flow phase and
this is the first five six seven days of
a woman's menstrual cycle and you might
also hear the flow phase called the
teardown stage and what's being torn
down is the lining of the uterus is
being torn away and being shed and
here's a science word here the
endometrium is the name for the lining
of the uterus and you can see this
nicely in the picture the un-- in the
first five six days here the endometrium
is at its thinnest that's because the
endometrium the lining has shed and and
exited from a woman's vagina through
menstrual bleeding and now we move into
the second stage of the menstrual cycle
which is called the follicular phase and
in the word follicular I hope you can
see a reference to the word follicle so
what's happening is the lining of the
uterus is being rebuilt because you
never know the woman might become
pregnant so the lining of the uterus is
beginning to thicken and this will
provide oxygen and nutrients if a woman
indeed does become it does become
pregnant and usually around day 14 is
when ovulation occurs and this is again
why it's called the follicular phase is
if you look at the top of the picture
the follicle is maturing and at the end
day 14 at the end of the second stage
the follicular phase the follicle has
broken open and the egg is released so
the second stage kind of centers around
the follicle that's why it's called the
follicular phase and a woman if you're
if a woman is kind of keeping track of
her ovulation and she may notice a
slight temperature increase in body
temperature increase this is again
because of the rising of hormones if you
look at the graph at the bottom estrogen
levels are rising luteinizing hormone LH
is rising and so this is characteristic
of the second stage of the menstrual
cycle
and it's in these days now where a woman
is most fertile most likely to become
pregnant now that the egg has been
released there's about a 24 to 48 hour
window where now that that egg has been
released it can be fertilized and so we
move on into the third stage of the
menstrual cycle called the luteal phase
and in the word luteal is reference to
the hormone luteinizing hormone LH and
so what's happening in the lining of the
uterus notice how the lining of the
uterus is at its thickest the
endometrium is at its thickest well this
will provide extra blood and nutrients
in case the woman becomes pregnant and
an embryo were to implant into the
lining of the uterus also now that the
follicle has ruptured at the end of
stage 2 the follicle ruptured releasing
the egg that ruptured follicle kind of
collapses and becomes what we call the
corpus luteum and during these months
notice how in the graph below there's a
rise of progesterone and that's really
because of the corpus luteum so in the
graph you can see around day 16 17 18
the gold line the yellow line begins to
increase in rise that's because the
corpus luteum is releasing large amounts
of progesterone and the purpose of these
hormones is if an egg is to become
fertilized then these hormones will
prepare the endometrium the lining of
the uterus in case the egg is fertilized
the lining of the mute of the uterus
will be prepared for the embryo to
implant and so this monthly process the
menstrual cycle will continue until a
woman hit a stage in in development
known as menopause and this is when the
menstrual cycle stops and usually this
happens in a woman's 40s to 50s again
it's a little different for each woman
but that's generally the time pattern
when this occurs
and the reason for menopause is that
there's a decline in these hormone
levels that we saw on the previous
slides
the LH the FSH the estrogen and the
progesterone there's a decline in these
hormones which makes the menstrual cycle
very irregular and ultimately the
menstrual cycle stops completely and at
that point there's there's no more
elating so if a woman's not ovulating
she's not having a menstrual cycle and
can no longer become pregnant some of
these symptoms and side effects of
menopause you can see in the picture so
there you go there's a hopefully a quick
introduction on the female reproductive
system if you want to pause this video
and work on these questions if you're in
my biology class you can write them down
in a separate sheet of paper and I'd be
happy to check your answers before
school or after school good luck